[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv78 en direct de
l'Université des maires de l'Ouest
parisien pour ce débat consacré à la
sécurité avec comme invité Geoffroy Bax
de bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire du
Perray vous êtes qui plus le plus jeune
mère je crois des Yvelines c'est ça
voilà ça dure pas tout le temps mais
[Rires]
ça peut et vous avez fait installer dans
votre ville un système de vidéo
surveillance dont on va parler dans
quelques instants à côté de nous Laurent
Rochette bonjour bonjour vous êtes de
Seine Yvelines numérique alors c'est une
organisme qui dépend du département oui
des deux départements Yvelines et
Hauts-de-Seine et qui apporte des
services numériques mutualisés au
bénéfice des deux départements mais
aussi de l'ensemble des communes et des
intercommunalités
et vous agissez beaucoup sur ce dans ce
domaine et puis Robert Vallières bonjour
bonjour Alors vous présenter Yvelines
fibre alors Yvelines fibre c'est une
filiale de TDF c'est ça tout à fait donc
Yvelines fibre en fait c'est une fibre
c'est un opérateur d'infrastructure en
charge du déploiement de la fibre
optique sur 150 communes rurales des
Yvelines et TDF en fait c'est un grand
groupe c'est une vieille dame qui est
qui diffuse déjà à la radio FM notamment
qui diffuse la TNT qui met à disposition
des opérateurs mobiles des des points
hauts et puis qui également déploie la
fibre optique sur une partie de la
France voilà et vous avez participé
l'option de vidéo surveillance de la
ville du Perray nous avons eu cette
chance alors je me tourne vers le maire
d'abord c'est vrai que la question de la
sécurité est une question essentielle
pour les administrer oui tout à fait on
est justement on est dans une période
qui est compliquée on a des montées de
conséquences que l'on peut constater
dans certaines communes nous aujourd'hui
on a voulu agir principalement sur la
prévention en installant cette vidéo
protection on avait également des des
faits comme des dépôts sauvages de la
petite délinquance petit trafic de
drogue et on voulait agir dès maintenant
sur ces sujets là et pour nous ça nous
paraissait naturel d'avoir de la
vidéoprotection sur la commune donc qui
couvre une grande partie de la commune
les grands axes les entrées sorties de
ville pour être en capacité voilà quand
il y a un incident on est capable de
revenir dessus de remonter
ça aide voilà à apaiser aussi la voie
publique à aider nos agents de police
municipale à faire leur mission c'est
vrai que aussi à côté ça vous avez une
police municipale importante opérer
alors moi j'ai une petite police
municipale petite ville petite police
mais trois policiers municipaux mais ça
fonctionne bien ça fonctionne très bien
et on avait vraiment ce besoin justement
quand vous êtes peu de policiers et bien
vous avez besoin de les outiller de les
accompagner de leur donner les outils
nécessaires pour assurer leur mission et
c'est pour ça qu'on a installé cette
vidéo protection sur la commune il y a
eu une époque où quand des villes
installées ce qu'on appelait des caméras
de surveillance ça faisait tout un débat
est-ce qu'on peut le faire est-ce que ça
tente pas aux libertés je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le débat est dépassé
enfin ça fait plus débat quoi même plus
pratiquement plus de villes qui n'ont
pas un système de ce genre oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui on a présenté le projet
on avait d'ailleurs prévu de le Phaser
en plusieurs années à l'origine on
voulait mettre quelques caméras par an
on s'est rendu compte que par l'effet de
subventions et par l'effet de marché et
bien on avait des prix plus attractifs
on était capable de financer une grosse
partie de notre projet et c'est pour ça
que l'on a décidé de le faire carrément
en une année on a installé tout notre
système de vidéo protection sur la
commune ça fait toujours débat vous avez
toujours une petite partie de la
population mais très sincèrement nous
avons même été étonné parce que c'est
vraiment à la marge les gens sont
d'ailleurs plus aujourd'hui à vous
demander mais pourquoi vous en avez pas
mis devant chez moi
qui à vous dire pourquoi vous en avez
mis une et vous avez installé cette
système alors cette année on a commencé
à installer on a installé cet été c'est
opérationnel depuis septembre voilà donc
c'est un peu tôt pour dire on a déjà des
résultats on a déjà des et bien c'est
tôt mais il y a déjà des résultats quand
même il y a déjà des résultats je prends
des exemples on a eu des réquisitions
judiciaires on en a déjà eu 6 6
réquisitions judiciaires dont deux qui
ont permis où on a permis d'aider à des
enquêtes que je peux pas évidemment
détailler mais on a réussi à apporter
des éléments des preuves pour des
enquêtes qui concernent des enquêtes de
niveau départemental et puis on a aussi
du quotidien parfois vous avez du
mobilier urbain qui a été mais je prends
un exemple un camion qui a fait tomber
un lampadaire barama en fronde c'est
4000 euros à remplacer mais un 4000
euros quand on a retrouvé le celui qui
l'a fait on est bien content alors vous
avez raison vous parlez de prévention au
départ et puis là vous parlez d'enquête
je discutais avec les représentants de
la gendarmerie tout à l'heure qui me
disait oui la vidéo surveillance ça nous
aide beaucoup en matière d'enquête de
revoir des images évidemment de quand il
y a eu des des
voilà ça sert aussi beaucoup les forces
de police de gendarmerie dans les
enquêtes oui tout à fait et puis on a
quand même on a une caméra qui sont
aujourd'hui les caméras modernes elles
ont des logiciels qui sont développés on
a ça relève par exemple toutes les
plaques d'immatriculation qui rentre qui
sortent dans la commune deux jours comme
de nuit et donc quand vous avez une
enquête un témoin qui vous parle de
d'une personne qui a fait un incident
nous en tapant la plaque
d'immatriculation ou un bout de la
plaque on est capable de retrouver les
personnes qui sont passées de
ré-identifier
bah voilà les potentiels contrevenants
et donc ça c'est c'est un gros plus
aujourd'hui les caméras d'aujourd'hui
sont une grosse aide dans l'exercice de
mission de police et encore une fois
vous avez pas d'admi stricts de dire
comment on est surveillé c'est
il faut bien comprendre quand même que
ces réglementé aujourd'hui les caméras
qui ont des protection les images sont
enregistrées pour seulement 30 jours
elle s'efface automatiquement au bout de
30 jours donc il y a pas de on peut pas
remonter en arrière pister les gens etc
on n'est pas non plus en Chine où il y a
une reconnaissance des visages
aujourd'hui c'est quand même très
encadré
n'importe qui ne peut pas ne peut
accéder aux images il faut être habilité
agrémenté par la préfecture pour avoir
accès à ces images de vidéos donc c'est
la police ce sont c'est le maire mais
c'est très peu de personnes seulement et
puis il y a pas ça dépend mais on n'est
pas non plus dans le flics des gens
aujourd'hui on souhaite on préfère avoir
nos policiers sur le terrain à exercer
leur mission
plutôt qu'à être derrière appliquer les
gens ça nous sert surtout à revenir en
arrière mieux enquêter parce que les
cambriolages dans le département on est
tous concernés une ville comme la mienne
qui est finalement qu'on peut considérer
comme calme mais pavillonnaire donc vous
avez beaucoup de cambriolages et
aujourd'hui grâce à ces caméras de
protection on peut réussir enquêter
retrouver les personnes qui ont commis
ces faits Robert Vallières
participer à la mise en place de cette
vidéo surveillance
en fait nous avons été contactés par par
la commune du Perray pour qu'on lui
présente la solution qu'on pouvait
proposer avec basé sur notre solution
fibre donc fibre qu'on a déployé pour
sur toute la commune du Péret dans le
cadre du déploiement FTTH donc pour les
particuliers et en fait c'est les câbles
que l'on a déployés ont des fibres qui
sont dédiées pour des applications
entreprises pour des applications pour
les collectivités et donc en fait on a
présenté cette solution donc à la
commune du Perray pour leur montrer
qu'elle pouvait être les avantages de la
solution fibre optique et c'est assez
simple au fond oui c'est ça vous vous
câblez pas
vous vibrez je peux dire le territoire
pour les pour les particuliers qui
veulent internet on sait ça oui oui tout
à fait et c'est un peu le même système
qui permet un peu différent peut-être
alors c'est le même système à part qu'on
est sur un circuit qui est complètement
fermé c'est à dire que on n'est pas sur
le monde internet qui rentre dans le
dans le Cloud on est dans un système qui
est complètement fermé donc c'est
totalement hermétique c'est-à-dire que
la caméra parle toutes les caméras vont
jusqu'au centre de supervision et c'est
tout donc il y a absolument aucune
aucune ouverture vers l'extérieur donc
on sait ça tout de même la différence et
je pense que ça c'est extrêmement
important vis-à-vis des problèmes de
sécurité ou des contraintes
administratives pour pas que ensuite des
visages apparaissent sur le net à gauche
ou à droite ce qui est je pense en plus
totalement interdit vous avez combien de
caméra on a 50 50 à la fois donc c'est
en fibres et à la fois en radio en radio
alors on a les deux on a on a veut dire
quoi en radio et bien c'est à dire que
les images sont transférées par
fréquence radio donc il y a deux
solutions à la fois radio à la fois
fibres et en fonction des endroits on a
privilégié la solution fibre qui était
plus adaptée pour certaines emplacements
et d'autres radios voilà c'est une
dépense de combien à peu près le dépense
elle est importante pour nous c'est une
dépense de 330 000 euros quand même pour
installer l'ensemble de de ces caméras
mais il faut savoir qu'on a la chance
exceptionnelle d'être dans le
département des Yvelines où nous avons
une participation du Conseil
départemental et du conseil régional
aujourd'hui
cet investissement je n'aurais pas pu le
réaliser sans cette sans ces aides là on
est aidé à 30% sur les caméras on peut
être aidé à 30% sur les caméras au titre
du contrat départemental des Yvelines on
a pu financer les caméras on a pu
financer la fibre à 70% grâce au conseil
départemental des Yvelines et le la
région Île-de-France subventionne les
caméras de vidéoprotection à hauteur de
35%. donc aujourd'hui on a des
financements très importants j'ai oublié
de préciser l'état l'état nous a
subventionné à hauteur de 79 euros
pas beaucoup non donc heureusement qu'on
a le Conseil départemental des Yvelines
et de conseil régional qu'ils ont
subventionné chacun à plus de 100000
euros donc ce sont des financements très
importants et comment ça se passe quand
on lance
un marché comme celui-là il y a un appel
d'offres oui tout à fait voilà on a on
fait appel classiquement à nae Mo qui va
un bureau qui va nous aider à monter le
dossier et puis on lance un marché
soit vous le faites en propre soit vous
pouvez faire ça avec Sony numérique
d'accord Laurent Rochette
scène Yvelines numérique fait aussi du
travail de vidéo surveillance absolument
on a démarré il y a maintenant
quatre ans ou 5 ans avec un programme de
vidéoprotection bâtimentaire orienté
protection
c'est-à-dire que on dit aujourd'hui une
vidéo protection c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt la terminologie aujourd'hui on se
concentre sur la protection des
populations
mais vous avez raison c'est une urgence
importante alors effectivement il y a 4
ou 5 ans on a démarré pour le compte du
département des Yvelines un programme de
vidéoprotection bâtimentaire beaucoup
les collèges sont très collègues dans
les Yvelines et on est passé d'une
situation dans laquelle finalement
chacun parce qu'il y avait déjà de la
vidéo protection précédemment sauf que
ça s'était installé avec le temps les
matériels étaient obsolètes finalement
les conditions d'utilisation étaient
peut-être pas idéales et le les systèmes
en place on avait 113 collèges 113
systèmes différents donc une un problème
une complexité
et puis une certaine obsolescence donc
quand on est allé sur le renouvellement
de ces systèmes on a proposé d'avoir un
seul système pour les 113 collèges et
bien sûr on a greffé aussi d'autres
bâtiments départementaux des bâtiments
administratifs on est allé voir certains
de nos part je pense aux pompiers qui
ont parfois aussi des problèmes de
sécurité bâtimentaire et qui ont bien
voulu nous faire confiance on couvre
aujourd'hui la protection en vidéo de
plusieurs casernes de pompiers
et tout ça est ramené au sein d'un seul
centre qui va pouvoir superviser cette
24/24 les images et là on a là aussi
très vite des résultats on a eu
l'occasion
à de très nombreuses reprises de fournir
des images à la police et à la
gendarmerie sur réquisition judiciaire
alors vous occupez vous dites des
collèges des bâtiments publics les
privés peuvent faire appel à vous
alors les privés non par contre les
communes et les communes pourraient
faire appel à nous effectivement c'est
un sujet qu'on a travaillé parce que ça
nécessitait une modification des textes
il y a des textes qui étaient plus
tellement en concordance avec les
besoins actuels à savoir il faut
mutualiser autant que on peut le faire
pour faire des économies au niveau des
communes pour pouvoir proposer des
systèmes mis en commun on dit il faut
des opérateurs 7 24 24 ça coûte
excessivement cher donc si on peut
puisqu'on les installer ces gens là pour
la partie bâtimentaire on peut proposer
ce service là aussi aux communes mais
les textes qui dataient des années 80 le
code de la sécurité intérieure etc ne
permettez pas d'aller vers cette
mutualisation on a fait un gros travail
d'explication certains diraient de
lobbying auprès de d'administration
ministérielle et du Parlement et on a
fini par obtenir effectivement gain de
cause avec une nouvelle loi enfin un
article de la loi sécurité globale votée
au printemps 2021 qui nous ouvre
maintenant cette possibilité dans notre
centre mutualisé de pouvoir lire
exploiter des images de vidéos
protection sur la voie publique ce qui
présente je parlais de cette avantage en
termes de mutualisation on voit bien
l'avantage économique mais il y a aussi
cet avantage du temps réel quand on peut
avoir un caractère de flagrance sur
quelque chose qui est commise assez
produit par exemple la semaine dernière
dans un des bâtiments qu'on surveillait
et puis et puis enfin il y a une
question aussi de continuum géographique
souvent nos partenaires police et
gendarmerie demandent les entrées
sorties de ville parce que ils ont
besoin quand un délier est commis de
savoir où vont où vont effectivement les
auteurs des faits délictuels voilà donc
il y a un vrai problème
que plusieurs communes
syndicalise leurs efforts si enfin
bettons communs
pour acquérir de la vidéo protection
absolument tout à fait c'est l'objectif
qu'on se fixe puisque c'est la demande
d'un certain nombre de communes
notamment sur le territoire des Yvelines
mais également en haut de scène de
communes se sont signalées sur ce type
de besoin récemment alors les communes
font face comme vous le savez sans doute
des défis économiques on parle en ce
moment beaucoup du coût de l'énergie
évidemment vont renchérir les
difficultés économiques pour les
collectivités donc tout ce qu'on peut
proposer comme service mutualisé
évidemment c'est un avantage de ce point
de vue là et puis nos partenaires police
et gendarmerie et la justice bien sûr
voit bien l'avantage l'intérêt pour eux
en termes déficience et de flagrance
j'ouvre est-ce que toutes les toutes les
communes de visibles sont occupés de
vidéos protection ou est-ce qu'il y a
des petites communes qui n'ont pas
encore les moyens tout le monde n'est
pas équipé de vidéoprotection après je
pense une grande majorité des communes
ou à minima quelques caméras sur les
entrées sorties de ville ça c'est
souvent quelque chose qu'on retrouve un
peu partout maintenant c'est un choix
politique de décider si on a envie
d'équiper plus il y a le choix politique
de peut-être le choix économique aussi
de temps en temps
plus petites communes ou ce qu'on peut
voir de temps en temps c'est que les
communes ont plutôt des caméras qui sont
vraiment en centre-ville parce que en
centre-ville ben ça coûte moins cher ben
oui parce que en fait la liaison est
direct en plus et l'école avec
éventuellement de la radio et c'est à
partir du moment où il commence à y
avoir de la distance où il commence à y
avoir des arbres qui vont entre
l'Amérique et la caméra que les choses
se compliquent et c'est là où il faut
plus de technicité et ça c'est ce que
peut apporter un ami ou ce que peut
apporter sa ni num en ayant en apportant
ce support justement est-ce que la
technologie c'est beaucoup améliorée
dans les dernières années sur ces deux
balles
ah oui la technologie c'est beaucoup
améliorer d'abord ça a été mentionné
tout à l'heure sur la qualité de l'image
donc on arrive à faire des zooms et donc
avoir plus loin de manière plus précise
donc ça c'est vraiment important sur la
qualité des images y compris de nuit ça
c'est un premier point et alors le
deuxième point c'est ça a été mentionné
aussi tout à l'heure c'est
l'intelligence embarquée dans les
caméras du point de vue des logiciels ou
la typiquement je vous parlais de la
vidéo protection bâtimentaire sur
l'ensemble du parc bâtiment terre du
département des Yvelines nous remontons
près de 4000 flux vidéo simultanément
alors vous imaginez on peut pas regarder
4000 images c'est pas possible donc du
coup pour pouvoir garder cet efficience
il y a des logiciels qui vont détecter
sur les images qu'il appliquent sur
lesquels il se passe rien
qui vont détecter et afficher uniquement
à ce moment-là afficher des images
qui ont été quelque part préqualifiés
par un logiciel et à ce moment-là il y a
une levée de doute humaine voilà donc là
l'intelligence artificielle
absolument et on peut programmer les
choses sur tranche horaire par exemple
dans la cour d'un collège c'est tout à
fait normal qui est des gens la journée
et la semaine et particulièrement en
semaine par contre à deux heures du
matin un samedi 1 à 2h du matin il y a
beaucoup de raisons il faut peut-être
faire une levée de doute peut-être
quelqu'un qui passe tout à fait
légitimement le concierge ou voilà mais
ça peut aussi être une intrusion une
tentative de cambriolage alors deuxième
question que il faut aborder parce que
c'est c'est un des grands enjeux des
années qui viennent c'est la question de
la cybersécurité on voit beaucoup
d'établissements publics des hôpitaux
qui étaient très récemment attaqué
pris en otage d'ailleurs par des hackers
est-ce que c'est un problème quand on
est maire comme ça qui qui vous angoisse
ou qui vous qui vous interpelle en tout
cas alors oui ça nous interpelle je
dirais pas qu'on est angoissé par ça
mais
les enjeux de cybersécurité je crois
qu'on le retrouve à tous les étages sont
dans l'industrie que dans les
collectivités aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
a un temps de retard là dessus les
collectifs en France et je crois qu'on a
un gros temps de retard
nous c'est à titre d'exemple sur ma
commune on a commencé à
revoir tout notre système informatique
etc mais on manque aussi de moyens
d'expertise pour avancer sur ces sujets
là donc à défaut on fait avec les moyens
du bord donc je crois qu'il y a un temps
de retard
évidemment et on peut-être par là je
vais peut-être plus sensible sur les
enjeux informatiques etc donc je je fais
cette progression là mais on est
tellement pris dans plein de choses que
finalement je pense qu'on est beaucoup
de mairies avoir un temps de retard là
dessus donc c'est un enjeu vraiment
important des avis qui viennent Laurent
Rochette justement et Yvelines
numériques accompagne les collectivités
sur cette lutte contre la
cybercriminalité
oui absolument on aperçu ce que vient de
dire monsieur Bax de Keating on aperçut
il y a à peu près un an effectivement
que les cybercriminels finalement avait
tellement attaqué les entreprises du
secteur privé qu'elles avaient fini par
bien se protéger qu'elles sont plus
difficiles à atteindre c'était moins le
cas des collectivités du monde public de
manière générale y compris le monde de
la santé et que à ce moment-là les
cyberpirates se tournent beaucoup plus
vers le monde public même si on va dire
la valeur marchande des données
peut-être moindres il y a un effet
psychologique un caractère très
important des données personnelles par
exemple on l'a vu avec l'hôpital de
Corbeil sur les données de santé qui ont
été maintenant exposées et donc on a mis
au point tout un accompagnement des
collectivités des et des établissements
publics qui le souhaitent qui est la
disponible depuis la rentrée on a déjà
une bonne dizaine de communes qui ont
fait appel à nous par exemple en
Yvelines la commune d'Achères
ou encore la communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et qui
viennent chercher chez nous justement
cette expertise on a tout simplement
créé une équipe on a quatre personnes
dans cette équipe on a travaillé sur un
parcours de cybersécurité qui passe par
d'abord se former puisque on le dit
toujours c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on
répète la première faille elle est
humaine c'est on va cliquer sur un lien
d'un faux mail ce qu'on appelle le
fishing et qui va créer une ouverture
sur le sur le système ensuite il faut
évaluer la manière dont on est exposé et
puis ensuite mettre en place des
protections et enfin prévoir au cas où
on est attaqué prévoir un dispositif
donc tout ce parcours là assez éveil
numérique il existe et on le propose à
l'ensemble des collectivités et bien
donc les communes peuvent faire
merci merci à tous les trois c'est
beaucoup merci de témoignage donc de
cette
vidéo protection ce serait la prochaine
fois et donc la vidéo surveillance merci
beaucoup à tous les trois merci merci
[Musique]